oliver gaz bonsoir toi avant de parler
de son nouveau livre pianiste je
voudrais faire référence à deux clichés
qu'on trouve dans 90% des des articles
qui te sont consacrés le premier c'est
quelque chose que toi tu connais très
bien mais je suis sûr qu'il ya beaucoup
de téléspectateurs de lunettes qui
savent pas c'est que tu as un des plus
grands auteurs mondiaux si ça arrive je
suis ici et que tu as commencé à écrire
à l'âge de 40 ans parce qu'un to be put
avait trouvé une une tumeur au cerveau
et que toi tu t'es dit il faut
absolument que ma femme et de quoi vivre
mais quand je serai mort alors je vais
écrire des livres s'est vue d'être comme
ça oui c'est vrai le deuxième cliché
qu'on voit partout mais c'est que bien
entendu tu as écrit orange mécanique qui
est devenu le le film de kubrick
ça ne me plaît pas beaucoup parce que
leur pays se sont lassés des nécessaires
pour moi d'écrire la situation parmi les
jeunes n'étaient pas libérés on parlait
pourtant on parle de la possibilité de
briller cette violence on les vieux avec
des techniques pavlovienne et j'ai
décrit la situation à ce moment et on a
fait un film ça ne pouvait appliquer
très beau vert en france mais pas de
toit en toit
dans le film on voit trop clair la
violence et en conséquence depuis vous
disais pas trop pour moi peu trop pro
graphique alors tu sort un nouveau livre
qui s'appelle pianiste et une chose que
je comprends pas toi qui est un
linguiste qui connaît très bien les mots
en anglais il ya deux mots il ya piano
player qui la veut dire celui qui jouent
dans les clubs celui qui joue dans les
cinémas enfin qui jouait à l'époque du
muet dans les cinémas et puis un
pianiste qui est le concertiste et
comment ça se fait qu'en français tu
accepté que ce soit salie sorcières est
difficile d'estimer ses ordres et de les
deux professions et de boulot parce que
à mon avis un pianiste raison qu'ils
jouent bien oui piano et bien cordes et
il a des deux reçoit des
applaudissements à la sphère de à la fin
de son père commence mais pour ma femme
pour moi et pour mon papa
le boulot de voiliers de deux se
rejoignent et joaillier jouer ce climat
de tous les temps tous les unit est une
histoire et dont il est question d'avoir
un piano très fort qui éprouvait
supprimés mais les to et les rires
et il ya un bon père quand il est vrai
que
bourgault continuer les quantités de
consister à la capacité à imposer tout
le temps parce que les images du cinéma
ancien cinéma changer tout le temps
alors ce qui est bizarre c'est que bon
tu racontes des histoires très personnel
l'histoire de ton père qui a été
exactement piano player l'histoire de ta
mère qui a été et club dancer quand on
perd son mari l'épousé d'un camp orange
mécanique tu racontais finalement que
c'est un peu l'histoire qui t'es arrivé
avec la première femme cirque elle avait
été assassiné par des par des voyous
c'est très bizarre c'est tu as publié
une offre une autobiographie qui
s'appelle wilson haendel en angleterre
qui va être bientôt publié en france et
comment ça se fait que un an avant tu
publiés en ligne
il raconte la même chose mais en général
de national dans les mémoires compte de
la vérité mais
c'est le doigt du rancié prendra des
l'amour la vie quotidienne et en faire
quelque chose un peu plus visa pour un
divertissement ce livre versys de style
c est ce que tu as vu les premières
critiques qui sont sortis sur ton sur
ton livre en france et en construire
elles sont un peu un peu réservé par
rapport à d'habitude on dit c'est un peu
facile et dernier chapitre sont sont un
peu bâclé c'est une liberté proche du
je-m'en-foutisme en fin de vie et qui
arrive de même il ya des
bon il est terrible comme tu dis mais
grâce à dieu on l'a mis oui oui oui
alors je vais te faire une interview
maintenant tu sais dans cette émission
fait des interviews à concept judiciaire
une interview who's who
alors beethoven quand j'avais 19 ans je
voulais devenir beethoven alors qu'est
ce que tu penses de beethoven pourquoi
vouloir devenir veto mais n'est pas
mozart est pas et pavillonnaire et à
jean sébastien bach et mongongu mag ont
des ambitions devenir une espèce de
beethoven britannique
c'était pas possible de ne pas
totalement mais je compose de la musique
beethoven pour moi est de plus grands
génies dit dominique mais
malheureusement il a détruit de musique
peut-être le dernier grand musicien et
et motta parce que avec béton on a
commencé à apercevoir l'entrée de la
paix est d'inviter compositeur alors en
continu friday tu as fait un ouvrage sur
freud est trop discret frei d'alors paul
ii pour moi zeghida découvert
l'inconscient et pour moi froid et
explique toute chose il est libéré huit
feux sont produits étaient
les nuits mais pour moi mes rêves sont
bien expliquées par utile dérive ou bien
croisé utile oui c'est ça et pour un
gros nez n'en doute comme unique qu'est
ce que ça fait au milliard dans la fin
du siècle pour bagarre l'angleterre
battue c'est avec sur montrouge qui est
une amie très proche mais l'inconnu en
revanche on ne connaît bien
tu l'as lu le livre les versets cette
année où je suis et j'ai dû tout séjour
je vais tout ces votes c'est que je
ferai bien les versets sataniques au
livre des trucs parce qu'on dit qu'elle
reçoit mais on a le droit je crois de
présenter dans le personnage de tintin
dans le roman le une
situation dans ce territoire si je peux
pas moi par exemple si j'écris un roman
dans lequel il ya un message qui dit
jésus-christ et bata de sa mère était
pas si tu essaies douze disciples
étaient homosexuels c'est possible si un
jeu dans ses paroles à la bouche d'un
personnage et où jeter a fait ça sur moi
évidemment les
justement ne comprend pas bien la cure
mal compris la distance qui avait entre
le romancier et son personnage c'est ça
que je veux dire mais je crois que bush
qui avait besoin d'un peu de discussions
et les billets les médias les mets et
les peurs les corrections de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus